good morning believe nation today we're
going to talk about five ways for you to
stay focused how do you stay focused
answering this question is perhaps the
most important critical thing you will
ever do in your life time period so I
hope it is an absolute priority for you
to learn to take back your focus in life
for you to get more distinct and more
clear about what your focus really is
and for you to finally decide you know
what if I don't finally get my focus in
check if I keep wandering around
distracted if I keep looking at every
new thing that pops up if I keep trying
every single new opportunity if I keep
saying yes to everything if I keep
listening to everybody's complaints and
if I keep doing whatever they ask me to
do at some point you'll lose your life
and I don't mean that physically as in
harm or death I mean that one day you'll
wake up and say I don't feel like I've
accomplished what's meaningful to me I
don't feel like I'm in a job that I care
for I don't feel like I have connection
with my family or my friends because at
some point your focus drives everything
it drives your thoughts and your
emotions right while you focus on is
certainly if you focus on the negative
things are gonna be negative if you
focus on if you fail to focus on the
things are important meaning your
priorities then what happens to your
relationships what happens overall
quality of your life focus is driving
everything in your life you got to get
back
Oh
one of the things that's very important
in life is that whatever you focus on
the longest becomes the strongest I
heard something that said act the way
you want to be and soon you'll be the
way you are why is that I'll be faking
ourselves out no we're not what we're
doing is we're calling forth those
things that be not as though they were
and eventually you will get into the
mindset eventually it will create a
difference in your attitude and you
begin to produce those results that
you've been imitating but now they
become real to you because you operating
from a place of truth one of the things
that when I look at my life I wanted to
be on television and so what I did I got
a picture of myself and I watched the
Phil Donahue show I had a dream of
becoming a talk-show host and I put my
picture over the television set I
listened to Phil Donahue what I was
looking at me and I was acting as if and
visualizing myself being a talk-show
host and I started telling all my
friends I'm gonna have a talk show when
I'm not sure but if you know somebody
and get me on please let me know okay
and so eventually that became a reality
when you begin to focus on something but
you focus on the longest becomes the
strongest that's why act the way you
want to be and soon you'll be the way
you act is so important because your
thoughts have magnetic power and you
begin to attract and joy to your
experience those things that you
visualized pick a product pick a
position pick something to focus on and
then have the business discipline to
really focus on that one thing and do it
brilliantly even personally it more and
more I think you know ultimately build
your personal life around five things
and that's it and build your business or
your team around five key opportunities
and say no to everything else and that's
the secret of mastery if you look at the
true masters they basically worker that
one thing they didn't
we created everything I just finished my
Monday morning meeting with my team and
we went over what I call my eight
priorities and this is for for this year
the whole organization all our energy
all our raisers all our focus is really
around the eight things that are on this
page right now and any other
opportunities that come in when pretty
much say no to it any other speaking
opportunities that come in if they're
not aligned with you know the tours that
we have on the schedule for this year we
say no to it and that brings up an
another key point which is most
businesses run into trouble not because
of too many good opportunities but
because they excuse me not because they
didn't have enough good opportunities
but because of too many good
opportunities so they were going here
and there and everywhere and they got
really busy being busy so they couldn't
focus on those five key things or that
one big opportunity focus focus focus a
key thing to building a great black
brand building a great business and
building a world-class life so flow or
focus is all about eliminating
distractions so what are the
distractions right now that are keeping
you from being focused go ahead and sit
down pause this video and jot down five
things
what are five things that are keeping
you distracted in whatever area of life
you want more focused in so are you not
focused at work
what is distracting you is it hunger
because you're not eating in the morning
is it your boss who comes in and
disturbs you every 15 minutes or is it
emails is it the Twitter feed that's
pinging you is it your cell phone that's
vibrating from text that you're getting
hit up with well you know what is
distracting you what about at school
what's distracting you there what about
in your relationship what's distracting
you there sit down and identify those
factors because once you've got those
identified and I think what you'll find
is actually that one of the biggest
factors that you'll find is multitasking
you trying to do multiple things at one
time and that of course is antithesis of
focus when you're doing multiple things
you are not focused by definition you're
splitting your focus and when you split
your focus it's like you know what it's
like it's like imagine if
we had the Sun it was a bright sunny day
and I gave you a magnifying glass and I
said here you can take this magnifying
glass and if you hold it up at the right
angle and you hold it steady then you
can burn that ant right there on the
ground or you can set that leaf on fire
and at first thought you'd say like wow
that's if you didn't know that you say
well that's that's amazing I can't
believe that's true let me try it then
you take that magnifying glass and you'd
run over and you try to burn an ant or
burn a burn a piece of leaf and but of
course if you didn't listen to the fact
that I told you you have to keep it
steady and you have to focus the raids
that was can happen is you're going to
just kind of move move it around move it
around move around and you're gonna come
back to me to say what the hell nothing
worked this this you're lying to me this
doesn't work it's not possible to take
the sun's rays and burn anything with
them they're they're too weak and of
course the problem is that you didn't
focus the Rays first that's exactly what
its life and you're like in your life if
you're trying to get some success in
your career and your business at school
what you need to do is you need to put
your your full attention on it right you
need to bring all those rays to a point
you need to bring your thoughts to a
point your mind has to be focused on
whatever it is that you're doing focus
is controlled by questions if you ask a
different question continuously not once
continuously you will get a different
answer if you ask a lousy question you
get a lousy answer in a lousy state so
why does this always happen to me it
doesn't always happen to you but the
brains like a computer asking a question
it'll have to come up with an answer
because you deserve it you idiot someone
will say how come I can never lose
weight you can't lose weight but if you
keep saying how come I can't ever lose
weight that means gotta come in answer
goes you're a pig lousy questions great
what lousy answers ask a better question
get a better answer now here's what I
want you to get I want you to get that
you can change your state how fast guys
how fast how fast and if you get the
habit of doing it you have a different
life you must define your mission
you need to have a mission for what
you're doing today you need to have an
intention for what your next task is
going to be what happens most people
just kind of show up and they go okay
well I guess I'll do some stuff but they
have no intention whatsoever so they end
up doing too many things that mean
nothing towards their mission you should
figure out what is it you desire in life
and figure out the steps to get there
and start working a plan to get there
and minimizing everything else getting
very clear on the mission very clear on
the mission and working the plan
everything else guess what it gets a no
until you reach that mission or until
you're significantly on your way that
you have free resources to be able to
focus elsewhere and that's what people
do they take on too many projects
because they're not clear about their
mission because I'm guessing if you're
watching this you know you're somebody
who wants to add value and make a
difference in the world so anytime
someone to ask you to do something yeah
let me help you but that might not have
anything to do with the quality of life
or the objective or the thing that
you're trying to achieve or the service
you're really intending to offer right
and I know how hard it is because I'm so
pulled myself towards causes and towards
volunteerism towards helping so many
people but guess what if I help
everybody in lots of different areas I
might not make my ultimate mission of
serving the people I want to serve the
most of making my dreams come true so I
could support more people of running my
business so I can support more people
meaning it's easy to take your eye off
the ball if you don't know what the ball
is and people often have never defined
their mission and if you don't have one
right now for this day if you didn't
have them drive a mission a written down
statement about what you were going
accomplish today a checklist a goal
sheet a time management tool that you
filled out today and you're just showing
up today and going well I guess I'll see
what my inbox tells me to do today and
you just respond to everybody else's
desires and everyone else's emails and
usually always in reaction always
responding to everybody no proactivity
towards a mission that you defined
yourself you'll be lost
you'll find that because you never
focused on that one thing or moving
towards those several things that were
your priority that you're just lost
because and here's another thing focus
goes out the window when we don't have
progress right if we're not progressing
toward something our focus goes out the
window we just we don't pay attention to
anything we don't feel good about
ourselves you want to get more focus in
your life get more progress as you
progress the more you start to get
excited you start to pay attention to
things that are working that are moving
you forward and you start to find more
focus in your life
thank you so much for watching I made
this video because Abdul Majeed asked me
to so there's a topic that you'd like me
to cover in the next edition I believe
life leave it in the comments below I
will see what I can do I also love to
know which of the clips that you saw
today left the greatest impact on you
it's going to force a change in your
life somehow leave it below and I'll
join in the discussion finally my goal
is to hit a million subscribers on this
channel so anything you do to help
spread the video share it with friends
tell people about it I really really
appreciate it thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and I'll see you soon
so give up all blaming give up all
complaining you remember Martin Luther
King's great speech I have a complaint
remember that
no he said I have a dream how many of
you saw the secret I was backstage I
didn't get to see that either most if
you haven't seen it don't just read the
book watch the movie the movie is much
more impactful to me book the books
valuable because you can think about it
stop and read and so forth
but the movie is just kind of take you
on a ride at the end you're different
and we talk about that movie focus on
what you want not what you don't want
too many times people for I hope that
doesn't happen I hope I don't miss my
plane
I hope the microphone works I hope my
book gets old you know whatever don't
ever think about what you don't want
only think about what you do want don't
complain just be grateful for what you
have Law of Attraction 101 focus on what
you do have be grateful for it be
grateful for the things people do focus
on the positive aspects of people not
the negative and then the positive will
look spa expand what you focus on grows
that kind of thing